en primer lugar Cómo se hace un análisis
general de este discurso porque Trump
volvió a presentarse como una víctima de
los demócratas a los que acusó de llevar
al país a la ruina
Buenas noches
histórico para la nación norteamericana
un día donde la presidencia de Estados
Unidos la institución de la presidencia
nunca volverá a ser lo que fue antes del
día de hoy en el discurso de Trump yo lo
interpreto como una persona que está
viviendo en otro mundo que no quiere
enfrentar la realidad de lo que ocurrió
hoy Esto es un discurso básicamente
político atacando al presidente Pero en
ningún momento se dirigió a los a los
puntos específicos de lo que ha sido
acusado 34 cargos extremadamente
queridos uno puede argumentar que este
tipo de caso no lleva al nivel de lo que
debería ser para romper la tradición
norteamericana de no encausar a ex
presidente y la la estabilidad política
que esa política esa política de no
encausar a expresidentes ni ha traído al
país el razonamiento de esos que
argumentan así dicen Si vas a romper esa
traducción tienes que hacerlo por un
caso verdaderamente
importante como son los tres casos que
se están investigando y a punto de
concluir el caso de los documentos el
caso del asalto al Capitolio el día seis
de enero y el caso de tratar de influir
a los oficiales de yonkia para que
cambiaran el resultado de la elección en
este estado no un caso que va tras casi
20 años sobre puntos específicos de
haber tratado de cambiar documentos para
y elevarlo un nivel más alto Este es en
contra argumento pero el presidente
Trump esta noche en lugar de contestar
los puntos específicos de esos cargos
básicamente va un discurso de candidato
presidencial
a todo el mundo y yo creo que tiene que
tener cuidado en la forma que habla del
fiscal porque el juez lo puede mandar lo
puede lo puede castigar lo puede poner
restricciones para que no siga
difamando a una persona
bueno pese a todos usted lo estaba
mencionando él tiene otras
investigaciones de mucho mayor peso en
este momento procesos de mucho mayor
peso en su contra Pero puede decirse que
Trump Está sacando ventaja de esta
situación es una imputación el primer ex
presidente de Estados Unidos imputado
pero vemos Que a Trump con este tipo de
situaciones le va bien
exactamente él lo que está es
solidificando su base dentro del partido
republicano esa base ha ido creciendo en
los en las últimas semanas
respuesta al este posible encausamiento
el muchas muchos de las personas que lo
apoyan a él han han fortalecido su apoyo
y estiman que este caso no se hubiera
traído contra otra persona que no se
llamara Donald Trump que la
falsificación de documentos en el estado
de Nueva York normalmente es lo que se
llama un mix de miner que es un delito
de menor cuantía y aquí lo han elevado a
una felonía diciendo que se falsificaron
los documentos a nivel Estatal para
tratar de cambiar o afectar la ley
electoral que es una ley federal así que
tenemos un fiscal local de Manhattan
acusando a un expresidente
una técnicalidad de haber cambiado
documentos dentro de su jurisdicción
pero para Elevar el caso o nivel de
felonía dice que esa falsificación se
hizo para romper la ley electoral Así
que la es una teoría bien bien original
no se ha presentado nunca a la corte y
hay quien dice que este queso se va es
ese caso va a ser despedido por los por
los jueces es que eso nunca llegaría a
juicio Por otra parte si llegara a
juicio ese caso para que Trump fuera
convicto tendría que tener el Jurado
unánime en contra de él van a ser doce
personas con que uno de los doce diga no
yo estimo que no se presentó evidencia
suficiente para condenar a Trump Trump
saldría absuelto es por eso que muchos
dicen si vamos a tomar Este paso porque
hoy se ha cruzado el rubicón en la
historia norteamericana hoy se ha
cruzado el rubicón
Tenemos muchos países especialmente
países tercermundistas donde los
expresidentes se encausan por cualquier
cosa y eso Crea una inestabilidad total
Estados Unidos nunca había sufrido de
eso y lo que se Argumenta es si vamos a
cruzar el rubicón deberíamos haberlo
hecho con un caso de una importancia
mucho más grande que la De haberle
pagado 130 mil dólares a una actriz
porno bueno Trump usted ya lo decía él
está sentando bases dentro del partido
republicano y de hecho algo que llamó
mucho la atención fue que líderes
republicanos del Congreso llamaron a
Alvin brack para que entregara
documentos para que entregara
información sobre este caso algo que
Brad dijo que violaba los procedimientos
judiciales del estado de Nueva York esto
sólo puede pasar con alguien como Donald
Trump
eso te indica hasta donde está llegando
el punto de polarización y hasta dónde
están sufriendo las instituciones de
este país que el congreso que es una
rama totalmente independiente trate de
inmiscuirse en la decisión de un fiscal
local y le pida que le entregue
documentación yo creo que eso
sobrepasa la línea que siempre ha
existido una línea de respeto una línea
de separación de poderes y te demuestra
que aquí se están destruyendo las
instituciones en este proceso tú puedes
estar a favor de Trump en contra de
Trump pero lo que no se puede negar es
que las instituciones gubernamentales
que han llevado más de 230 años para
crear y el respeto que se tenía hacia
los expresidentes y el rol tan
importante que los expresidentes han
tenido a través de la historia
norteamericana de unir al país en
momentos difíciles todo eso se está
tirando por la ventana por la defensa de
bueno llama también la atención esta
esta referencia bastante amplia que hace
sobre el caso de obstrucción a la
justicia en los documentos clasificados
diciendo que él no iba a ir en sí que él
cuando desclasificó estos documentos que
fueron hallados por el FBI en su
residencia él era presidente tenía la
potestad de desclasificarlos en cambio
que con el caso biden lo que pasa es que
él era vicepresidente y no tenía por qué
retirar estos estos documentos estos
textos clasificados Pero sabemos que en
el caso de biden según lo que hemos
podido conocer fueron los mismos
abogados de biden quienes entregaron
estos documentos a los archivos
nacionales Entonces qué podemos analizar
al respecto
Mira de cualquier forma los documentos
nunca se debieron haber llegado llevado
de la casa blanca y de los recibos
nacionales ya sea lo haya hecho biden o
ningún expresidente incluyendo desde
luego la diferencia es que cuando
termina la presidencia ese último día en
la casa blanca es caótico los los vienen
los camiones de mudanza empiezan a
cargar cajas y llevársela o a los
lugares que han sido designados como
depósitos de esos de esos archivos o en
muchos documentos se llevan también a la
casa de los expresidentes o a lugares de
seguros que ellos han alquilado para
mantener esos documentos Así que el
hecho de que se hayan llevado los
documentos no es el el pecado mortal
aquí el pecado mortal viene el que
cuando los archivos nacionales se dan
cuenta que los documentos faltan en el
caso de Trump le piden por las buenas
que devuelva los documentos él se niega
a hacerlo Después
en los archivos nacionales van ante un
juez y le piden al juez que ordene a
Trump que esos documentos
devueltos y ahí es donde se consigue que
dos abogados de Trump firmaran una
declaración jurada diciendo de que ellos
daban fe de que no habían más documentos
en marolago
los archivos nacionales sabían que eso
no era cierto porque le faltaban
documentos aún Y entonces es cuando le
dan al juez y piden una orden que para
que hacer el allanamiento de mano lago
entran los agentes del FBI y encuentran
más de 150 documentos de más alta
clasificación incluyendo algunos dentro
del propio buró de Donald Trump Así que
donde donde caemos en terreno muy
difícil es en el terreno de la
obstrucción de la justicia no tanto el
hecho de que sean llevados los
documentos Pero si los documentos fueron
llevados y se hizo algún uso siniestro
de ellos que todavía eso no se ha legado
pero si se demuestra que Trump utilizó
esos documentos para algún propósito
siniestro y que él sabiendo que tenía
sus documentos en su posesión le dio
información para que sus abogados
representaran una falsedad a la corte
Eso sí es obstrucción de Justicia bueno
algo que también defiende vehementemente
Donald Trump es la persecución en su
contra no Solo lo dice del fiscal del
distrito Alvin brax sino de la fiscal
general del estado de Nueva York de
Leticia James de Alvin Brad dijo que es
que lo persigue que quiere capturarlo a
cualquier costo lo acusó de fracasado y
dijo que no hay ningún caso en su contra
Pero entonces qué es lo que estamos
viendo en estos momentos en Nueva York
en la audiencia y lo que vivimos hoy con
el primer presidente imputado primer
expresidente imputado disculpe
Mira yo creo que estamos en una en una
línea muy difícil muy muy frágil porque
es cierto que a él se le encausó por a
todo el mundo estuvo hablando dos años
de la conexión con Rusia que no llegó a
nada después él fue
le hicieron dos impeachments tampoco fue
fue convicto por el senado Así que los
seguidores de Trump dicen esto es una
persecución política y el mejor ejemplo
que tenemos ahora es este caso de Nueva
York un caso Generalmente visto como un
caso de menor cuantía en comparación a
lo que es el perder la estabilidad
política que le ha dado al país el no
encausar expresidentes por cosas tontas
muchos consideran que esto es una
pequeñez en comparación a lo que estamos
perdiendo que sí se está demostrando que
no hay nadie por encima de la ley es si
lo que el fiscal de Nueva York hoy alega
se demuestra que es que es cierto pues
efectivamente tenía la base para
encausar al ex presidente Trump La
pregunta es
debió haberse perdido Esa esa el aura
que rodeaba la presidencia para encausar
a una persona por un nivel de delito
bajo en comparación a los otros tres
investigaciones que están pendientes y
el hecho de que el fiscal que causa es
un fiscal demócrata que durante su
campaña hizo varias alegaciones diciendo
que iba a seguir adelante con los casos
en contra de Donald Trump otro factor
también cierto es que el juez que
preside este caso es el mismo juez que
acabo de presidir el año pasado el caso
contra la institución de la corporación
de Donald Trump donde se encontró
culpable de fraude al de Nueva York y
mandaron al jefe ejecutivo de esa
compañía al señor a la cárcel donde
todavía cumple sentencia Así que el
hecho de que sea el mismo juez que esté
presidiendo este caso
te hace yo yo preferiría que que no
fuera el mismo juez yo preferiría que no
fuera este el caso que abriera el
proceso de los encauzamientos a un
expresidente creo que hay otros casos
más importantes para hacerlo bueno y
algo que llama la atención es como este
tipo de situación deja la imagen de
Trump dentro de los republicanos Por
ejemplo si la comparamos con figuras
como ron de santis o Mike pence cuando
vamos de Cara a unas primarias
republicanas
mira en este momento
Trump se ha acogido todo el oxígeno de
toda la prensa norteamericana y en gran
parte de la prensa mundial los otros
candidatos y el propio presidente biden
no importa lo que hagan en estos días No
importa lo que digan ni siquiera se les
cubre
Trump tiene captada toda la prensa el
oxígeno político Todo se lo ha llevado
él y le va a ser difícil a otros
candidatos republicanos de levantar
cabeza ahora es esto al corto plazo o a
largo plazo se mantendrá esta situación
Yo soy de opinión que cuando empiecen a
salir los los datos sobre estos casos
especialmente si hay otros
encauzamientos en los otros tres casos
que yo Considero que son más importantes
los propios republicanos se van a dar
cuenta de que es inmantenible este
estado de crisis constante de que nos
los republicanos no van a poder ganar
porque sí gana Trump gana la primaria
Pero va a volver a perder la lección
general el pueblo americano yo creo que
está cansado de todas estas crisis
semanales de todos estos insultos de
todos ya tenga corazón o sin razón pero
cuando tú te conviertes una figura tan
polémica Yo creo que tiene un límite
hasta donde tú puedes llegar y Trump
desgraciadamente perdió sus límites en
la forma en que él personificó la
presidencia los ataques personales que
hacía la forma irreverente Aunque tú
estuvieras de acuerdo con muchos de sus
políticas muchas personas no estaban de
acuerdo con sus mensajes de Twitter con
sus insultos llega un límite hasta donde
el país está dispuesto a aguantar estas
cosas